[Music]
you've clearly had a very impressive
career but before becoming one of it
that's not what my mother says before
becoming one of the top venture
capitalists in the world being knighted
by the Queen you were a boy from Wales
what did you want to be when you grew up
I actually not that this game or sport
has played in America and so it won't
translate I wanted to be a cricket
player a cricketer but I was a coward
and the ball was very very hard and so I
spent most of my time in sport whether
it was cricket or rugby trying to avoid
being anywhere near the ball so I have a
friend actually who became a spectacular
rugby play played for Wales which and I
told him that the only thing that
separated him and me on the rugby field
was when he took to the field he wanted
the ball to come in his direction and I
of course wanted the reverse I never
wanted to see it come in my direction so
but as I got a bit older I became
interested in journalism and when I was
at Oxford you and I knew that I wanted
to be a journalist when I was a dog so
I'm interested in the story of how your
family came to Wales it was quite
inspiring that your parents actually
escaped Germany during the Second World
War
arriving in Wales as refugee it's in the
UK as refugees how did their struggles
and their experience shape you early on
and sort of what you wanted to do with
your life well they they were very lucky
they didn't escape during the Second
World War they escaped beforehand not
many people escaped Germany during the
Second World War and my father left
Germany he was born in Munich and went
to Britain when he was a four
ten year old my mother went on something
called the Kindertransport
which was ten thousand kids from Germany
basically that were that were rescued
and put in with in foster homes and they
then met subsequently in Britain and
after the war they they got married and
you know there's a searing experiences
difficult and I'm sure every you know
there are people here either who have
first-hand familial experience of
something as disquieting unsettling and
wrenching as those sorts of experiences
but those are the experiences that come
down through generations my father's
father served in the German army during
World War one he was decorated who and
my father's mother was a nurse in the
German army during World War one and
then both of them were killed they were
murdered by the Nazis and my father died
about 15 16 years ago my mother whom I
saw last week is 95 and still vibrant
but those experiences they color
everything they hang over everything
like like a dark cloud it is always the
anxiety and the fear of the whole world
being ripped out from underneath you and
and it and it colors the way that you
live yeah understandably and that drives
you today still well I don't know about
that but it certainly had a profound
effect on my my parents and and and they
came to Wales as outsiders
and obviously britain i owe everything
my parents of everything to the fact
that britain opened its borders and
allowed them to settle there but it was
not easy they were in a minority there
weren't exactly I mean I was one of I
think three Jewish kids at the high
school that I went to so I've always you
know one always felt an outsider and the
delineation between religions in Britain
which is you know 4050 years ago was
very very sharp and so if you didn't
belong to the majority it was very
obvious that you were on the outside so
that's obviously had a huge effect well
you did them very proud you worked
really hard he would get into Oxford and
I'm sure you had many opportunities
professionally in Europe but you decided
to come to the United States why why the
United States well I didn't have many
professional opportunities in Europe
because I grew up in the you're in the
Britain but predated Margaret Thatcher
and those were extremely difficult times
in Britain I mean obviously Britain's
going through its own issues today with
brexit but the times in the 1970s people
who weren't around and there's no reason
that anyone here should should know
about it but it was a strike ridden
country where you never knew whether the
electricity was gonna work whether
there's gonna be a gas strike whether
the railways would run or whether the
newspapers would be delivered because
there'd be a wildcat strike and I wanted
to be a journalist and I wanted to work
on Fleet Street and I wanted to work for
The Times or The Daily Telegraph or
Guardian or one of the big broadsheet
newspapers that at that point dominated
journalism in Britain but because of
Union restrictions the feet street
newspapers the big newspapers were not
permitted to hire anybody straight out
of undergrad you had to go and
of multi year apprenticeship on small
provincial newspapers and I had no
appetite in doing that I just I wanted
to work on Fleet Street I wanted to sort
of work in the Premier League so to
speak and I had a I went to see a
gentleman who was the editor of The
Daily Telegraph a fellow who he was a
Fleet Street legend and a character on
whom evil in war had based the novel
scoop which is hilarious if you've never
read it and he said if I was your age
get out of Britain go to America and
that was the that was what sent me to
America was that sort of weird peculiar
encounter and I often think about that
that's that's what made me up sticks and
leave I mean well you know I and I was
lucky I got a sedentary had I not got a
scholarship because I didn't have the
money and all the rest of him and but I
got lucky and that and I came to America
this is 1976 not knowing where anything
would lead but have obviously stayed
here 40 years he said so you started out
when you got here as a journalist for
Time magazine in San Francisco actually
not in San Francisco in a Detroit able
place in Detroit covering the first
collapse of the Chrysler automobile
company and then you made your way to
San Francisco to cover technology and
during this time you got to know Steve
Jobs what do you believe made jobs such
a unique innovator and leader in the
time that you spent with him so this is
again this is a long time ago this is
1980 and Microsoft was a company that I
remember going to an event at Apple one
of these sort of management events small
management events probably this is 1982
or 83
and Steve had a sort of fireside chat
like this and he asked the guest fellow
who at that point was a Morgan Stanley
analyst called Ben Rosen who later went
on to found a very successful venture
capital firm use it so Ben pick the year
when Microsoft you think Microsoft will
break the ten million dollar revenue
barrier right ten million dollars and
Ben was scratching his head so it's a
very very long time ago but well that
was the only point I was lamely trying
to make and but I realized I hadn't met
anyone like Steve I'd spent time with a
fellow called Lee Iacocca who was a
living legend in American industry at
that point and had been the president
the Ford Motor Company and then became
the CEO of Chrysler and Steve was the
first person who salesmanship was on a
par with Iacocca's Iacocca was just
mesmerizing character but he didn't have
the product and engineering attributes
that Steve had obviously there was a
difference in age of probably 35 40 35
years or so but Steve was a Spellbinder
and I and obviously as everybody knows
these days a a very difficult and
complicated character but he was an
extraneous extra and even though I had
lots of I had all sorts of issues and
dealing with him have nothing but you
know massive admiration for what it is
that he eventually went on and went on
and did and
but as I said it's a long time ago and I
think at that time I probably held a
minority opinion of how spectacular and
individual he was because later he was
again
ancient history he was fired from the
company and that he found it which to me
always seemed like a real travesty
so following your time with Time
magazine you would make the switch to
the venture capital industry by joining
Sequoia which is very uncommon how did
that happen
well I'd left time because while I'd
enjoyed four years or so as a journalist
I also got frustrated it was a big
company I was working on the periphery
of it and sort of for some reason it
always felt I didn't want to be a
journalist if I do when I was thirty
years old and I had that as some sort of
mental benchmark Koons knows where that
came from
I think was largely because again back
then I saw what happened to people he
was eye-opening to me I saw what
happened to people who stayed in
journalists and was 60 years old and
certainly if they worked for time which
was a sort of cushy job but you got sent
all over the world and you wound up as
an alcoholic
which appear to me to be a really
beckoning career trajectory left and
together with somebody else I started a
little company the published newsletters
staged conferences about the technology
industry and so much for mine and and
that fella stuck with it and eventually
many years later no thanks to me Dow
Jones bought that company and but I
always felt it was going to be a small
company and I heard through my work at
time through my work at this little
company I'd met a lot of people around
the technology industry and had met a
lot of people in the venture capital
business time had run a cover story that
I had reported on that about the venture
industry that had Arthur Rock who was
the original founder of int investor in
Intel and then of apple on the coven and
during the process of that had met a lot
of people in the venture business and
had horses and had when I came to
California I didn't know anything about
Silicon Valley didn't know anything
about the venture industry and had got
interested in it and and made a list of
five firms where I knew somebody wrote
to them you wrote to them in those days
he didn't email and God interviewed at
all got rejected at four of them
journalist history major no experience
working in a Silicon Valley company
therefore totally useless probably
correct on most of those camps and then
Don Valentine who was the founder of
Sequoia decided that he needed to do
something to change the Correa's image
with minority hiring
and so decided to hire a history major
and but it was a head scratcher for most
of Don's peers in the venture business
wondering why on earth he was wasting
his time with somebody like me so that's
how it happened it was a great good
fortune I if Don had said voted like the
others and I don't know what I'd be
doing so in the era of the prized
engineering degree in Silicon Valley
what value does that broad-based
humanities education bring given that
about 50 percent of last year's incoming
class came in with a humanities
undergraduate degree what value does
that bring to the technology ecosystem
here in Silicon Valley what do you think
well I obviously have a prejudice and
bias and knowing full well that I wish I
understood more about the details of
technology and engineering and all the
rest of it but if you're in the
investing business in Silicon Valley you
cover such a wide waterfront of
investing that it's very difficult you
can't be no matter how numerous and
technical you are you cannot be an
expert in everything so the ability to
be able to and this is much like being a
journalist to start on in an endeavor
where you know nothing where you gather
a lot of materials and facts where you
have to distill all of those facts and
then form a cogent opinion and make a
decision it's not unlike writing a story
writing a history essay or making an
investment or helping to determine an
investment what comes after that after
making the investment all the sorts of
things that these days go to
helping a little company in that might
be composed of three people becoming
something significant that's very
different set of skills which I think
just experience brings along it doesn't
matter whether or not you have a
technical degree or anything but and
then the ability to be a storyteller and
a clear communicator I think those are
really very very helpful pursuits but
again as I said I have a bias and
prejudice and I was looking at the
numbers you know a Stanford for example
you had 64 600 if I've got the numbers
right which is roughly right you had 647
undergrads in 1965 who a history major
in nineteen in 2014 which was the last
set of data that I saw you had 84 so
there are threatened species around here
well I think you put those skills to
good use at Sequoia given that it's
consistently listed as one of the top
venture capital firms and I have to get
this statistic right because it kind of
blew my mind when I first saw it so
since 1972 Sequoia has backed companies
that now have an aggregate public market
value of over three point three trillion
dollars to put that in relative size
that's larger than the current GDP of
the UK what are the most
that's work so so what do you think are
the most important leadership traits
needed to build enduring organizations
such as Sequoia well it's nice of you to
say obviously that's a question that's
at the heart of our heart of our pursuit
a Sequoia and also the heart of the
pursuit of the very distinctive
companies that we would like to be an
investor with and being able to think
and work in 20-year increments is such
an advantage and I know that sounds a
little weird and a little peculiar but
and obviously you can talk in a grand
fashion about a 20-year plan and it all
sounds very good but then you also have
to work on what this afternoon brings
but having a sense of eventually where
your compass is heading and where it's
set and the trajectory you want to go on
and then breaking it down into all sorts
of little steps knowing that every step
along the journey is going to require
different people different skills
different relationships different
virtues that you're constantly gonna
have to change along along the course
and reacting to changing circumstances
changing market conditions and all the
rest of it but never losing sight of
eventually where you want to go I think
that's the biggest thing that that has
helped with us and help with some of
these companies that we've had the good
fortune to be involved with now
obviously not everything works out like
that a lot of companies start and maybe
they flourish for a certain period of
time and then they're sold or but the
ones that we're looking for
I mean it's now where
20:19 it's 20 years since we invested in
Google I still learned the majority of
my Google shares and when when somebody
asked me today why are you interested in
why is the coin interested in investing
in our company I'll always say to them
if I think it happens to be true in
their particular regard because some
companies don't fit into that it's
because if we're all fortunate if the
Sun shines on us we can be shareholders
in your company 20 years from now that's
what we're today a B&B I think we
invested in Airbnb $600,000 in 2008 I
think it may be 2009 it's 10 years
happens like that and the company still
prime stripe which is a payment services
company we invested in when it was three
or four people that was 2010 again nine
years nine years later these are very
very long journeys that were on and it
takes time and patience and spectacular
people and the massive market
opportunity to build the real companies
that matter and have an influence and
great impact on on society in you and
Sir Alex talked about the importance of
identifying high potential talent in
building these types of organizations so
the example he used is a footballer some
of you may know by the name of David
Beckham who was pretty good
what characteristics are you looking for
when trying to identify this high
potential talent whether it be a founder
or somebody you hire at Sequoia you know
whether it's whether it's in part of the
reason either the reason that I
approached Alex to write the book about
Manchester United was the for whatever
perverse reason people have been asking
me to write a book about Silicon Valley
or Sequoia and I had no interest in
doing that but I was interested in
writing
out enduring organizations and I picked
United because it was a long way away
from Silicon Valley but because I knew
that he shared the approach that we
cherished as well
one of which who Patrick was the one
that you just fingered which was
identifying people when they are young
and then helping them develop and why
part of it is because you're not taking
a lot of risk Beckham I think you know
they they are they knew about Beck and
when Beckham was eight years old at
Manchester United now we're not going
around Stanford looking for
eight-year-olds but we do like hiring at
Sequoia people who were young because
it's a business that even though it
looks simple and today I understand
everybody's an investor from someone who
writes five thousand dollar checks to
somebody who writes a much bigger kind
of cheque but to do it well in the
fashion that we like to do it takes time
and patience and persistence and a
willingness to learn and assuming people
like that flourish you have incredible
loyalty and they'll stay with you
forever
and so that was true for a lot of the
players who played for us our Alex it's
and I think being able to grow
organically like that it's such an
enormous competitive advantage where you
have a stable team of people which are
always amending you're always changing
someone is perhaps no longer playing as
well as they used to play so you figure
out a way to deal with that but then
you're always replenishing the bench but
you're doing it in an imperceptible
fashion to people on the outside so that
all they see is you know in the soccer
metaphor the winning team on the field
without realizing that actually you know
there are two players on there today who
weren't
on that team 24 months ago but that's
work spectacularly for us we've got
these great roll-off toto
who's a graduate of GSB and he became he
went to PayPal and after PayPal he
joined us a Koya and that was probably
now 8 17 18 years ago and you know he's
just spectacular he's just one example
we've got a whole bunch of other people
like that so it's great one of the
characteristics you mentioned that I was
I was really intrigued by is this idea
of obsession so the best founders the
best athletes tend to be obsessed with
whatever it is the thing that they're
working on I was curious what do you
think obsession means to you
and how does it how does it feel what I
like how do you know it when you see it
there's a gentleman called approver
Mehta who's the founder and CEO of
instacart the online grocery company and
where we've been with approver on his
journey from considerable period of time
now and before we invested I asked him
how he had happened on grocery delivery
as a business that he wanted to be in
and he said he'd played around with and
toyed with a variety of other businesses
that he wanted to start and he'd got
down the road on I forget two three four
of those but he said the only one oh
here are realized
instacart was the one for him when it
was the last in the idea of the business
was the last thing that he thought about
when he went to sleep and the first
thing that he thought about when he woke
up in the morning and to me that was as
good a definition of obsession as as any
of I've heard but it's that sort of
full-on experience that that you can
never stop thinking about new and and
you don't switch off I'll give you
another example from yesteryear which
was again this is back to the early
1980s and
I had been not in Seattle working on the
story about Microsoft for time and again
this was when Microsoft was still
private and they're still quite small
and Bill Gates gave me a ride to the
airport in his car and not many people
can say that they were chauffeured by
Bill Gates in fact I may put that on my
LinkedIn profile above all other forms
of Education and there the radio was
missing in the car big gaping hole in
the dashboard and I said bill so what
happened to it you get ripped off and he
said no I had it taken out why do you
have it taken out well
I Drive from my home to the office which
is seven minutes and 32 seconds and then
I'll drive from the office to the
airport which is however long and he
said if I've got the radio I'm afraid
that I'll switch it on and I won't be
thinking about Microsoft that's
obsession I believe you
so the funding environment right now as
you alluded to is becoming extremely
competitive there are a record number of
programs to it you true there a record
number of new venture firms and capital
in the market Softbank just raised a
hundred billion dollar vision fund
Sequoia just raised an eight billion
dollar fund are there too many
investment dollars chasing too few and
best of all opportunities right now so
that's the line I've heard since 1986
with one or two exceptions maybe 1991
1992 and then right after the dot-com
blow-up when capital was everybody
understood that capital was scarce it's
always been a competitive funding
environment they've always been look how
many
how many companies get financed and then
how many become worth an you know become
tremendously important companies so if
you just do that we knowing and look at
the the funnel there are very very few
great companies so everybody is madly in
pursuit of those companies and and
therefore and obviously there are these
tangible examples of the enormous value
that's been created in the world of
technology in the last 30 or 40 years
and so money has poured into the sector
but for us it's always being this sort
of an almost always been this sort of
environment where a really spectacular
idea can get raised capital where
somebody who's starting your company
usually has choices of capital I mean
that's the world that I grew up in it's
the world that we've always operated in
and I suspect will be the world we
always operated it's just part of life
in our business so no bubble you're good
well there there are always look there
are always things that we will have done
others will have done that five ten
years from now will say to ourselves how
did we ever do something as silly as
that or wasn't it in nein or crazy or we
didn't anticipate this that or the other
so I'm sure we'll have a conversation
time to time again it's just an
occupational hazard so I want to talk a
little bit about how Silicon Valley has
changed there's content there continues
to be many discussions happening about
how to make make both technology
companies and venture capital more
diverse potentially beyond history
majors what responsibility does the
venture industry have to fostering
diversity in the technology ecosystem
the responsibilities of the valley of
firms like ours is to identify
burgeoning talent and the more the
merrier
from irrespective of gender irrespective
of background
irrespective of color now that's easy to
say and it's a bland statement and you
will then rightly say well what are you
doing about it and what are you doing
about it actively so we're doing what we
can but there's only so much that we can
do firms like ours a representative of
social trends and know a sort of sense
that this question might come up so I
turn the question around because I dug
up the data on diversity at Stanford in
majors and it's shocking so let me give
you some statistics so because I think
it's a this whole issue is one that all
of us have something to do about so and
I'll give you one little example say
from the math department in the
undergraduate program here and this is
germane I have a friend of mine whose
daughter is in the math department at
the moment and is thinking about leaving
the math department and switching to
another major because she is surrounded
by men and so in 1983 if you were an
undergraduate at Stanford
there was only 22% of the students who
had elected math as their major were
women guess what that number was in 2014
which is the last year when data was
available 22 percent in 1983 16 percent
in 2014 if you're computer science
graduate at Stanford the percentage of
women in the class in 1983 was 21% in
2014 20% and the only point I'm making
is we'll hire as quickly and as merrily
as we possibly can we have
seven female investment partners today
we've got I think close to half a dozen
female CFO CEOs that we've that we've
backed but we're a reflection of society
and we can only change as fast as the
rest of society will change but we're
more than happy to do our part we funded
all these different initiatives to help
help women in particular in technology
we have one of our partners jess lee is
working with something called female
founders but it's imperative for the
high schools and for the universities of
america to change before we'll see the
real acceleration in technology which
i've gotta say is a lot better today
than it was ten or fifteen years ago and
I think you know if you look at the
computer science numbers those are the
best numbers that I could find
at Stanford but even so they're not
overwhelming in 1983 the computer
science proportion the computer science
class here undergrad was 18% it
progressed but in 2014 it was still only
28% so there's tons of work for all of
us to do that's my only point so I want
to take our discussion beyond the valley
because investing outside of Silicon
Valley has become a very popular topic
as well for a lot of people including
Sequoia do you think this is still the
best place in the world to start a
company it's it's here and it's in China
and their trials and tribulations and
involve with with both places and
obviously everybody knows about how
expensive it is and the cost of living
and gross receipts tax in San Francisco
and all these other impediments that we
wish weren't here but my goodness
gracious me much as people here will
complain and moan about different
aspects of Silicon Valley you go to
places elsewhere around the world they
all wish they were Silicon Valley so
it's a spectacular fantastic place in
which
- in which to start a company and then I
was saying to your illustrious teen
before I came while we were chatting
backstage that I spent the last three
weeks traveling in China and Southeast
Asia I mean there was a vibrant places
one of the very big changes you know
China obviously everybody's read about
but Southeast Asia is really pulsing
with entrepreneurial activity and that's
a big change in the last five five six
years everybody knows about India and
talked about India but Southeast Asia
is surprisingly vibrant so there are
lots of you know the big change from
when I started in the in the venture
business a long time ago now was the
Silicon Valley largely Silicon Valley to
some extent Boston we had a hundred
percent market share give or take on the
most important technology companies of
tomorrow that's completely changed so
that so much of the investment now
occurs outside of the United States for
a whole variety of reasons so I want to
get a little bit of advice before we
turn it over to the audience so I think
we're all trying to determine how to
focus our time energy and resources upon
graduation if you were to put yourself
in our shoes today
what problems or industries would you be
focusing on maybe another way to ask
that question is where is Sequoia going
to be investing so we can skate to where
the puck is going to be well that's the
assuming that we know what we're doing
I've always found you know you go to any
website and every investors website
despite the window dressing they all
look the same and everybody's kind of
invested you know your your whatever the
buzz phrases of the ear are you will
read them on all the sites and you know
today it may be data science and machine
learning and artificial intelligence and
whatever the attributes are to me the
best investments are always the ones
that don't
in a convenient bucket and and so you
think about I mentioned Airbnb a few
minutes ago you think about Airbnb what
bucket would you have put a three
couchsurfers in in 2008 and in
retrospect it all looked so obvious oh
they're upsetting the hotel industry and
all the rest of it but at the time that
we met the company it was three young
founders who were sort of sleeping on
air beds and it was sort of pigeon-holed
as this very niche service for young
people who would ever have imagined and
I can point to any number of other
investments that seemed similar so to me
it's you know with years and years ago
Stanford you know this was an option yet
another offshoot of the incredible
fertile Stanford campus when we invested
in Yahoo the idea of investing in a
company that gave its service away for
free this is 1995 was totally foreign
came out of left field so it's those
investments the ones that aren't the
obvious ones that are the really
interesting ones we invested some years
ago in in DJI which is a drone company
in China
nobody had imagined it at the time that
we invested to do I think it did I may
be a bit off with the numbers but two
billion dollars in sales last year from
what seemed like a sort of little you
know nice little consumer toilet or the
beginning of the investment but which is
now becoming a company of substance
particularly as it expands into
industrial applications so it's the or
we're not in an unfortunate Lee we want
an early investor in uber but who would
you know luxury black car executive
ride-sharing is that ever going to
become a business you know if you switch
the clock back 10 years whenever over
got started it's another one of those
sorts of examples so that's
thing to look out for it's the
unexpected I'm gonna move to the
lightning round
what last chance anyone okay so I'll
explain the format as we go these are
supposed to be fun
one-word answers generally but a couple
lists so prioritize the following in
order of importance product team market
equal weight
unbelievable
it depends fill-in-the-blank
the greatest entrepreneur of all time is
whoever invented the wheel wow talk
about yesteryear the greatest individual
investor outside of the Sequoia
partnership is it's obvious you know
where he is in Omaha
what is one company you passed on that
you wish you had invested in I wish it
was only one uber we became late stage
investors in the company but I wish
would invested very early on what
percentage of success in VC is luck 101
percent the most underrated skill and a
leader is listening I thought you would
have said discipline what I thought you
were gonna say discipline for sure
listening listening listening listening
shows would you rather beat Liverpool or
benchmark we just concentrate on beating
them both
please join me in thanking mr. Michael
Morris for coming today
good job
[Music]